sigamos pensando en las derivadas
parciales de los campos vectoriales esta
es una de las cosas que vale la pena
practicar porque es un concepto
importante para el cálculo multivariable
así que vale la pena tomarse el tiempo
para tomar varios ejemplos y resolverlos
por ejemplo este que voy a ir separando
parte por parte voy a decir que tenemos
un campo vectorial que es justo este
tipo que tengo aquí y voy a decir que
representa una función una función
vectorial que depende de dos variables x
y de james y voy a decir que de salida
vamos a obtener algo también en dos
dimensiones cuyas componentes sean
funciones de xy de james así que
pongámosle un nombre así que imagina que
mi primera componente le pongo el nombre
de la componente p es una componente que
también depende de x y de james justo
como habíamos dicho ok y mi segunda
componente la voy a llamar
q va a ser una función que también
dependa de x y de 10 y bueno cualquiera
de estas dos componentes son funciones
escalares p y q son letras que se usan
en los teoremas de cálculo multivariable
con el hecho de que cualquier lector
piense claro q son las componentes del
vector salida del campo vectorial y
bueno en este caso en específico voy a
tomar la función que había elegido en el
vídeo pasado recuerdas en el vídeo
pasado había tomado como primera
componente es decir como la componente p
a la función x por james déjame
escribirlo x james y como segunda
componente como la función q a ye
cuadrada menos equis cuadrada recuerdas
esto es lo que habíamos tomado en el
vídeo pasado y en el último vídeo
estuvimos hablando acerca de cómo
interpretar las derivadas parciales de
esta función ven la función vectorial
con respecto a una de las variables es
decir la derivada parcial de este vector
bm y de hecho lo habíamos calculado
respecto a x lo cual tiene sus méritos
pero yo pienso que es importante para
entenderlo de una manera general sin
embargo en este vídeo no voy a hablar
acerca solamente de esto pienso que
sería mucho más útil y es lo que vamos a
hacer pensar estas derivadas parciales
en términos de cada uno de los
componentes y si pensamos en p y q
observamos que tenemos 4 derivadas
parciales posibles
tenemos dos de ellas con respecto a p la
derivada parcial de p con respecto a x
la derivada parcial de p con respecto a
yemen ok y también tenemos dos derivadas
parciales con respecto a acumula déjame
ponerlas aquí la derivada parcial de q
ok con respecto a x y también tenemos la
derivada parcial de q con respecto aa
ok tenemos estas cuatro derivadas
parciales involucradas ahora estas
cuatro nos van a servir para entender
cuál es su influencia en el campo
vectorial como un todo y en este ejemplo
en particular vamos a calcular las así
que vamos a fijarnos en la primera en la
derivada parcial de pep con respecto a x
bueno si observas la función p es la
función xy y como ahora estamos
derivando con respecto a x entonces
observamos la ye parece como una
constante y por lo tanto la derivada va
a ser simplemente ya y si calculamos la
parcial de p con respecto a ella
bueno va a pasar lo contrario en este
caso x se va a ver como una constante y
por lo tanto la derivada parcial va a
ser x
ok ahora para el caso de la función q
tengo que la derivada de q con respecto
a x de esto que tengo aquí me va a
quedar bueno la idea parece como
constante por lo tanto se va me queda
simplemente en menos 2 x menos 2x y por
otra parte la derivada de q con respecto
ayer si observas esto parece como una
constante se va y me quedan simplemente
2 siempre positiva 2
así que aquí tenemos las cuatro posibles
derivadas parciales y lo que quiero que
hagamos ahora es ver si podemos entender
cuál va a ser su influencia en toda esta
función vista como un todo que va a
significar en términos de la imagen que
tengo aquí y en particular vamos a
aplicarnos en un punto en específico se
me ocurre que tomemos a un punto que
esté sobre el eje x se me ocurre pensar
en este punto que tengo aquí donde es
igual a 0 y x tomo un valor positivo así
que imaginemos el punto no serna dejame
escribirlo por aquí vamos a fijarnos en
el punto x
ok y que sea igual al punto no sé se me
ocurre que x valga 2 y valga 0 ok vamos
a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa en este
punto y si sustituimos estos valores en
las derivadas parciales que voy a
obtener bueno si introducimos el valor
de x por 2 y de 10 por 0 entonces en
este caso voy a obtener 0
en este punto ok en este caso voy a
obtener 2
obtener menos 2 veces x lo cual me va a
dar menos 4 y por lo tanto aquí voy a
obtener 2 x 0 lo cual es 0 ok y una vez
que ya tenemos estas 4 derivadas
parciales evaluadas en el punto en el
que elegimos vamos a ver primero qué es
lo que pasa con esta derivada parcial en
el contexto de mi dibujo así que para
eso vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa
en la dirección x con los puntos vecinos
a este punto donde está anclado este
vector es decir vamos a fijarnos en este
punto de aquí
este punto de acá y vamos a fijarnos qué
es lo que pasa en la dirección x bueno
en este punto en particular observa que
no nos estamos moviendo en la dirección
x si observas a estos puntos vecinos
observa que están exactamente igual este
vector apunta hacia abajo y este vector
apunta también hacia abajo así que aquí
no existe un cambio en la componente x
de estos vectores lo cual tiene sentido
porque observa el valor en ese punto es
de 0 que es justo lo que nos dice
nuestra derivada parcial muy bien
entonces en este primer caso no
esperamos un cambio bien ahora déjenme
borrar esto porque vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa en el siguiente caso ahora voy
a pensar qué es lo que va a pasar cuando
nos fijamos en la derivada de p con
respecto a y esto que tengo aquí y ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que este tiene
un valor positivo entonces esto nos
sugiere que el cambio en la componente x
mientras nos movemos en la dirección
quién va a tomar un valor
y si vemos por aquí esta vez no nos
vamos a mover la dirección x sino que
nos vamos a mover en dirección james y
para eso vamos a comparar este vector
con este vector los vecinos de el vector
que nos estamos fijando y si observas
este vector tiene una componente x que
va hacia la derecha y este vector tiene
una componente x que va hacia la
izquierda y este equipo es 0 y eso tiene
mucho más sentido porque si observas la
componente x de este vector también va a
crecer estamos pasando de algo que va la
izquierda a algo que va a ser algo que
va a la derecha por lo tanto estamos
creciendo y eso tiene sentido porque
esta derivada parcial es positiva que es
justo lo que nos sugiere el valor de pep
que es nuestra componente en x del
vector de salida en este caso está
creciendo muy bien porque es positiva
ahora en contraste vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa con la componente q y para eso
déjame borrar esto que tengo aquí
vamos a aplicarnos qué es lo que pasa
con el cambio en x con respecto a la
componente y que en este caso si
observas es negativa así que de nuevo
vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa en
dirección x por lo tanto vamos a
fijarnos en estos dos vecinos en estos
dos de aquí pero ahora vamos a pensar en
la componente i y si observas aquí
tenemos un vector pequeño aquí un vector
que que es un poco más ya que un vector
que crece mucho más y de hecho se
mantiene creciendo y creciendo y
creciendo pero todos se están apuntando
hacia abajo y eso es porque tenemos un
crecimiento negativo en la componente y
se va volviendo más y más y más y más
negativo es decir estamos decreciendo la
derivada de q con respecto a x es
negativa y es justo lo que tenemos esto
mientras cambiamos en
y finalmente solamente para dejar las
cosas en orden vamos a fijarnos qué es
lo que pasa con la derivada de q con
respecto a james está que tengo aquí que
por cierto me dice que 0 cuando esto
acabamos el ejercicio así que bien vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa esta vez de
nuevo en dirección james pero ahora
vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa en
la componente y cómo cambia la segunda
componente de mi función vectorial con
respecto ayer pues vámonos de nuevo a
los vecinos me voy a fijar en este y en
este y si observas de aquí acá la
componente ya no cambia tienen el mismo
tamaño
aquí la componente james es ligeramente
negativa va hacia abajo y por aquí igual
es ligeramente negativa va hacia abajo
por lo tanto puedes ver que bueno en
definitiva no hay cambios significativos
al menos aa ojo de buen cubero tal vez
si esté cambiando un poco pero no a
simple vista y si nos fijamos de regreso
en lo que calculamos tiene sentido
porque dice que es igual a cero no hay
ningún cambio alrededor de ese punto en
la componente de éste
así que espero que todo este tipo de
análisis te ayude a tener un mejor
entendimiento de lo que significa o de
lo que representan estas cuatro
derivadas parciales y qué es lo que
indican en el campo vectorial y esto te
servirá para cosas como la divergencia o
el rotacional que son conceptos muy
importantes y que vamos a ver en los
siguientes vídeos pero por lo pronto
hasta ahorita lo que te recomiendo es
que practiques este tipo de ejercicios